you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hello there ladies and
gentlemen it's chris waters joined by a
crew of YouTube famous superstar
celebrity jeanetta yeah right now right
that's right well don't want me to call
them you are gonna be underwhelmed by
what we do and talk about then well we
like to you know build you guys up just
to watch you crumble in front I'm sure
if thanks so much watching and chatting
along they'll be sure to flame us in the
chat enough all right you guys joven
Shire what up very good we hear ye
lasercorn I you guys well known across
the tubes you Pippa we've been having a
lot of fun doing some Smosh games videos
hanging out at e3 and very glad to be
here now dude so we're talking III yes
and we're sort of last last segments of
e3 we're wrapping this show we're sort
of taking a look back how this e3 shook
out and in this segment we're talking
rumors versus reality what do we think
was going to happen coming into III
how'd it all end up shaking out so let's
start with one of the biggest rumors
where do you want to start there's so
many there were so many honestly I think
the rumors are always the most exciting
spot because you go into the the
presentation do you like oh my god I
hope they announce this I don't they
announce this well it's got to be that
either at the end of eight you're super
excited or you're just feeling a little
empty and cold inside like ah they
didn't talk about it oh but we had some
good ones coming into it though alright
so let's start off with
I got one right off the bat and this one
is sort of a rumor with a rumor tacked
onto it yeah so going in reception yeah
a lot of people were expecting to see
red dead redemption two ghosts right we
did not see a trailer for that and a lot
of people thought that game is not here
they didn't do it why didn't they do it
and it's funny because you mentioned the
rumor into a rumor into a rumor yes and
now the new rumor is that a PlayStation
was going to show it off at the very end
but they decided to scrap it at the last
minute because the trailer may have had
some untimely themes to it that they
just didn't feel like it was a good
thing given some rice and events and so
yeah wanted to be sensitive to it there
was absolutely but the the good news and
all of it is that red dead 2 seems to be
out there seems like it feeling pretty
bad for a rumor anyway yeah in the room
or a bird we don't know 40 back I mean
so either it wasn't there or the rumor
is true and they've just delayed it
until a better time which is I think
what we're all hoping yeah yeah I either
way we were sad to not see ya that did
not see it but also traditionally
rockstar games not a huge presence at e3
now you their own thing they can pull
the eyes whenever they want to they're
rock stars but at man do you remember
the reception when they showed the
trailer for grand theft auto 5 Oh like
we could have had that moment again and
I'm sad that we didn't but with that
said I also hope that in the next month
or two maybe we'll see that trailer what
is the next gaming event the next gaming
event ah well they got game that's not
really a gaming thing yeah baby gaming
something yeah calm yeah yeah games
comes another one that maybe some of
these rumors will stick to but the slot
in the sony press conference you're
talking about right at the end when they
did the sort of gameplay show off for
days gone yeah seemed a little odd why'd
they place that there why not put it by
the trailer earlier in the show another
rumor another sort of connected to
another rumor I've heard that maybe Sony
was thinking of announcing their new the
PlayStation niota teasing that a little
bit there's no sort of PS 14.5 I kind of
thing but that maybe they we backed off
after Scorpio ahead of time yeah yeah it
doesn't score they knew ahead of time
like our xbox is gonna say something
alright well are we going to say neither
that's just announced ahead
time yeah we got a neo there's a thing
that's coming will give you information
when they're actually needs to be
information and it's interesting Xbox
kind of want to want an interesting
direction because they're like the most
powerful gaming console ever it's like
well yes the first announcement of the
next generation y le PlayStation could
be sitting back and like we'll see about
that let us see what what your specs are
and then we'll show you the most power
most powerful gaming console ever that's
almost sort of kinda as powerful as a pc
yeah maybe yeah by the time it comes out
it's gonna be good get 4k it's got ya
excited about it all right let's talk
about I got the list here yeah another
big rumor we had coming in shadow of
Mordor yeah oh yeah one I was really sad
I actually I just felt it in my stomach
because I forgot that that was a rumor
never saw anything of it and I'm like oh
we didn't get that no that was a game
that I largely wrote off before it came
out originally I was like oh it's like
Assassin's Creed reskin with Lord of the
Rings and then it was incredible and
then I wanted a second one and now it
seems like we're not getting me now I
was excited to hear more about the Mafia
system that they utilize yeah that we
have not damages I'm sorry the Nemesis
systems so he called it the Mafia system
because immediately when they introduced
that system we were like imagine this
system in a mafia game when you're
trying to work your way up the ranks of
the Mafia ladder and be laid on what we
also talked about it in like a Batman
contacts where live Batman terminals if
you take one down lon de asís to someone
else fills the void yeah the nexus
system is so good the fact that any of
these games haven't utilized it say all
right well in shadow mode or two we'll
see it again it'll break but now we
don't see it nemesis you see honestly
I've spent so much time just
assassinating generals and people that I
didn't have to kill just to see what
would happen in a hierarchy in that game
yeah I feel like making them fight each
other yeah and then you sit back and
snipe and kill them both I know we have
many things to talk about but to give a
mini review of that great game I want to
see a second one because I did feel a
little underwhelmed with the first one
like you're taking over these mass
massive armies and at the very end you
kind of just take the generals and man
boil alert so I feel like a second one
would've been great to really see
how big middle earth is during this time
line well so that question goes hand in
hand with the rumor right why were you
excited to see the travels of Mordor too
because you liked the first one but now
you're excited to see what they do next
what do you want them to do next yeah
sure traditional characters do the grogs
it's like okay it kind of looks like
control it moves like it just call them
trolls you know just call them what they
are it was a lien like season made-up
character yeah as far as the Lord of the
Rings universe but it would be cool to
see his story maybe intersect with some
of the events of the movies yes and
great yeah well here's hoping baby maybe
next year maybe maybe next year all
right let's go down list he wrought this
one ended up paying off in a big way
Skyrim back on the scene oh yeah I'm not
let him talk he's gonna fill two hours
talking about us right now siren was so
happy like the rumor was there maybe I
even started the rumor because I wanted
it so bad it only made sense uh and as
soon as they they show stuff for in the
Bethesda press conference they're
talking about the shut up their game
their MMO game and then it's like oh yes
and we are working on it I'm like oh
yeah I know exactly what they're talking
about and then you just hear the music
and immediately it took me back four or
five years ago and you hear that theme I
go honking and it's just like you get I
was getting goosebumps I'm yelling at my
TV and I was on Sunday so I wasn't on
the floor I was at home actually just in
sweatpants typing I'm like yes I could
hear you through your tweet your tweets
were screaming at me on Twitter so if I
was to give a negative spin also I was
kind of hoping that with the
announcement of Skyrim HD which almost
seemed like a go-to and if your pc gamer
you kind of already have it where is
maybe an oblivion HD remastered or yeah
fallout fours success maybe fallout 3
and new vegas h so i think there's more
that they could have done there's always
more that you can do hiram already looks
pretty good yeah I could definitely see
an oblivion attracting a lot of
attention on absolutely
as a Skyrim superfan uh do you feel
comfortable with me identifying you that
way I you know I I can identify as that
yeah okay are you gonna play it again
absolutely I sit down on their this man
has your log like over a hundred out no
I'm not pretty late it more than once
have you uh no actually one there's so
much to do 212 two hours in one
playthrough and I will still do it again
the veins are popping in this man's neck
from exam it is very clear I'm also and
I understand i'm also more of a console
gamer than a pc gamer though i'm
definitely into that world more now but
to be able to play on my xbox one and in
play skyrim again and be able to relive
these memories with the mod support on
console I think it's great I'm just
happy I'm happy anything that brings
more mud crabs with you know monocles
and top hats into my life yeah he was a
fan of the My Little Ponies as drag yep
yep i potted on my little pony and
describe him that was horrifying their
way scarier than dragons are Jedi Sith
run with the lightsaber that's true uh
there's also a child killing mod so you
can go into an orphanage what me and
joven did and we had a lightsaber mod
and we reenacted yep the scene from one
of the other surgeries and we just got a
little battle look at those all visuals
or not say anything about these
individuals as in all right look it was
all one hellacious a modern take on a
Class A will not end all the classic
movie yeah all right onto another big
announcement Resident Evil there as Neil
seven of a new resident evil he made the
demo yet I have not played the demo I am
NOT a big scary horrifying little
nervous yeah I so you have played this
I've seen footage of it played and it is
like I couldn't like I started in full
screen and then like there was a noise
behind one of the doors and I'm like i
minimized like something's gonna jump
out at me yeah bevo and the thing that
walks by it's like what is that it's
very creepy I think we're gonna see some
scare videos what now it comes out oh
you see all my videos are crafted for
maximum manliness
didn't collect it yeah you I ever
screamed oxy look there's the footage
right now oh yeah if I mean it's pretty
small and far away but if you feel
unsafe what a huge ship from here it was
necessary they did behind them and I'll
shield what a huge shift from the other
resident evils we've been seeing you
right it was almost yet I feel like the
rumor was that it was going to be a
reboot and it seems like it is his
different gameplay giving different
characters different style but it is
still being called resident evil 7 and I
think mainly because the logo alone just
it you have to call 7 yeah because I
never even noticed get the be in the me
I in the AL like it's happened it's
right there in Japan it's called
biohazard you know the seven right in
the Z yeah it's too good not good
exactly which I actually i'm at logo
popped up on screen and a like everyone
got chills everyone freaked out by cool
i almost wrote off the trail because i
was sitting in a meeting for something
completely different i have but i have
like a headphone in with my laptop um i
guess so analytics and stuff oh yes oh
wait wait attention hang uh oh it's
something about before the kitchen
before they like I know that he's paying
attention in the did you play the
kitchen I played the kid it was great I
was free until I saw that was like okay
the kitchen's turned into a India game
and I'm Adam just watching stuff I'm
watching stuff I see res evil something
like what's what rewind rewind there was
nothing in the kitchen to suggest that
it was a resident evil lying at all and
the it's interesting because at the very
end of one of the endings of the the
playable trailer you hear them say
welcome to the family so it's not your
traditional g-virus zombie that can't
talk you know and I know they've
expanded and done las Plagas or anything
but they're not really going back to the
g-virus roots because those zombies were
not we're not big talkers no it's it's
did you ever try to talk to them I did
actually I moted and I was like
forastero Helion can be done yeah so far
a lot of enthusiasm for these
announcements and I think there's some
for the next one as well god of war we
were like all right man yep I was
another rumor first how did that develop
and then what we didn't know this is
something that you were like if they
don't say it I'm just going home well no
I didn't say I'd be going home look I am
a huge fan of the God of War franchise
and a lot of people did not like the
last installment 3.5
we call the god of war ascension is what
it was called the single-player largely
panned by people wasn't considered good
and I will even say not a good single
player experience the multiplayer though
and god of war ascension was so damn
good-looking name I am a pc gamer at
heart I play PC games but I stopped
playing every game but this game for 3
months straight when god of war
ascension came out because the
multiplayer was that good and I was just
hoping they'd bring it back that being
said you're disappointed that it's not a
multiplayer only reboot of God of now
yes quote me on that no I I was a little
I was a little dad looks so great it not
in the game when I saw this I was so
surprised by the new camera angle and
every yeah it it looks more cinematic
than the other games like I'm really
excited to see God of War told from this
perspective and more of it have more
storytelling elements I think behind it
and the way that they're able to to
expand on the god war universe in and
take a risk which is optimally like my
biggest pet peeve is like seeing sequels
that are just the same game over again
basically so it's really cool to see
them actually try something new and
speaking of since this is a rumor
segment this kid right here me and joven
were talking earlier this kid is his
name is Thor rumor the rumor to be Thor
and so kind of a theory we were spinning
is Kratos has kidnapped Odin's son and
is now going to for whatever reason take
out all the gods of norse mythology
which would be awesome but this is
clearly a more north themed god of war
we're seeing yeah wouldn't that be
amazing like if this is thor you kidnap
thor now all the Norse gods are
attacking just how how do you beat that
epicness how do you make Kratos even
more of an unlikable character a child
abductor yep well the whole problem was
it's like he's killed all the gods right
there's no where to go from here no he's
going to go find new God time film a
Pantheon and you got other lands sooo
i'm waiting Billy fights Jesus I'm sure
it's gonna help us to partner up with
smite and he'll kill all those guys
candy not playable Chris
there's there's your new rumor from here
will create oh he made it up right now I
think it's true I mean it seems it seems
like a no-brainer yeah lots of signs
point to it a lot literally seconds have
been spent to see you see immediately
pay off like a Roman pantheon right yeah
Greek pantheon he can get him there yeah
all right I naughty dog just released
uncharted 4 recently mm-hmm uh oh here
we go naughty dog this year at e3 about
maybe a more zombie filled game one it's
not last of us yeah that was another
rumor and again as soon as you said it I
was like that's right we didn't get that
yeah I'm just helping you relive just
all the pains of having the perlier day
be peaking by the way of excellent
innovative multiplayer we were talking a
little before we hopped on stage here oh
my dude last let's multiplayer still
lack of us probably like I would say the
best single player experience I've ever
had I loved it the multiplayer was
almost just as good it was incredible
said it was different it was unique it
was a gamble and that's why it was great
nailed it ah but no less of us in Alaska
3 2016 I what do you think well we're
gonna do a predictions segment later on
and so we'll get into that what we're
gonna see next year at e3 later on but
uh maybe last of us will come up then
mmm alright uh this one was rumored
ahead of time and actually end up being
revealed before e3 watchdogs yep yes
which they wave out all any why dogs
yeah if we were to be completely honest
okay good new and out what no is it
really they fixed a lot of sight I
played about an hour of the first one
before I gave up on it every single
person I've talked to that has tried out
the demo for watchdogs to says that it
is way better than the first one room I
haven't got a chance to try myself I
can't judge it you know don't quote me
but everyone's saying it's way better I
heard the rumor I was surprised about it
and then I we saw gameplay evidence they
go the world good job there we go now we
saw a strong base with the first one and
now it just seems like a much larger
world with with with great mechanics and
it's gonna open it up that Universal bit
more and I think the comparison a lot of
people have been maybe you know the
ideal situation is
assassin's creed two assassins creed two
yeah watchdogs to watch dogs yeah you
know it's really like hitting their
stride yeah not having to conjure
everything from scratch having that
foundation to build on to tweak having
all that knowledge from you know all the
feedback from players and all that stuff
when everyone is saying like the I don't
remembers name the character in the
first game was like so like lacking a
personality and that the new character
is so much more likeable much by way
love to see more personality in the game
ID actually a game like that that's kind
of all about I don't know their team
they may be over going a little
overboard in terms that I like hacker
Kitsch culture but honestly I kind of
like it's better than being too reserved
yeah i mean honestly it reminded me of
going back to like all the hackers
movies of the 90s and I was like all
right now I'm into this yeah I like the
vibe it's colorful it seems like fun I
was digging the the environment that
they were really creating all right uh
the rumor mill continues to churn
injustice too yep well see that was
another thing where I was like it was a
rumor but it wasn't like a rumor if you
did the math we knew we were gonna get
an injustice to in 2017 kind of math are
you doing here okay well into the math
where they switch off between and
justice in Mortal Kombat so every two
years you get another game you had
mortal kombat 9 then two years
afterwards was injustice and then two
years after that was mk10 and then that
was in 2015 so two years later be 2017
alright that's being justice too okay
here's III give us injustice to what's
behind curtain number one injustice to I
will tell the math ladies and gentlemen
that was great that was good and i will
say that i've heard some things about it
that give me some pause as far as the
competitive element of the game do you
guys know you guys got to try out a game
and you said yeah the gameplay was was
great yes what was your paws so i was
told that each character essentially has
five different pieces of their outfit
that you can swap in and out that not
just stats somehow that is correct and
i'm not sure how that's going to work as
far as normalizing things in a
competitive like an eSports setting I
think based on the conversations that we
had with them and you might be able to
know even more than I it seems like they
might maybe be working on something that
can
everything out also it kind of compares
to Mortal Kombat X in the nightstand
dances an olb it's really balanced in
the end well view sacrificers like for
instance if you put on like speed boots
do you sacrifice power how does that
work we didn't see any of that really
used wii yet i don't know if you can
well so the way I learned that there are
going to be you know gear items to equip
and injustice to was because I saw a
tweet that said yes they're gonna stairs
can definitely planning on are
considering at the very least
competitive modes in which gear items to
not be right okay so I sort of know
backfilled oh I guess there are gear
items in adjust but with that said the
gear and be able to switch up your out
on chair looks cool yeah amazing as a DC
fan boy I was like wait I can make him
look like what and I can do at okay can
I have this now please yeah and if you
watch the trailer they seem to really
enjoy their armor plating coming out of
nowhere it makes sense it was great for
the trailer when you see him yeah in
style looks good it doesn't always make
sense because it's injustice because no
amount of armor is going to stop
Superman spiking you in a threat armor
killing you in tonight over if you're
the flash now he's pulling his spike
banjo every logic you stop Joe like
emerald is not spy cam a basic logic
give me a light time mm-hmm really
raging logic debates on injustice who
will continue after we've always take a
quick break before the next segment
folks we are live from the e3 show floor
here on the game spot co-op stage stick
with us
you